[Música]
bienvenidos a áfrica siete días un
magazine informativo dedicado al
continente africano me llamo amalbert
man y estos son los titulares para
muchos se ha hecho justicia
34 años después de los sexos un tribunal
militar de burkina faso pronunció un
fallo histórico en el juicio por el
asesinato del ex presidente thomas
sankara su sucesor bless compaoré fue
condenado en ausencia a cadena perpetua
han pasado 28 años desde el inicio del
genocidio ruandés con ocasión de este
doloroso aniversario
hablamos de cómo fue usada la violencia
sexual como arma de guerra y analizamos
la situación del colby 19 en el
continente con nuestra especialista en
salud mar romero quien nos comenta si
realmente podemos considerar que áfrica
se ha librado de la dureza de la
pandemia en comparación con otras
regiones del mundo
comenzamos esta edición con las imágenes
de estos dos hombres el ex presidente de
burkina faso blaise compaoré y su ex
jefe de seguridad gilbert gender ambos
junto con díaz atc a fondo un militar
prófugo fueron condenados el miércoles 6
de abril a cadena perpetua por el
asesinato del ex jefe de estado
convertido en símbolo revolucionario
thomas sankara de los tres sentenciados
solo diendéré estuvo presente en la
audiencia ya que desde su caída en 2014
el principal acusado el ex presidente
blaise compaoré vive exiliado en costa
de marfil desde uagadugú la capital de
burkina faso nuestro corresponsal
callidus y nos proporcionó un resumen
del juicio
se trata de un juicio histórico que
finalizó el pasado miércoles ante el
tribunal militar de ahora de 34 años
después de la muerte del icono
panafricanista thomas sankara este
juicio es también 20 años de batallas y
procedimientos dirigidos por mariam son
caraduras de thomas sankara y sus
abogados maestros venimos de záncara a
la cabeza porque recordemos que él es
compadre el ex presidente hizo todo lo
posible para que el juicio no se llevara
a cabo y no fue hasta su caída en 2014
que la justicia burguesa reabrió
expediente este expediente de 20.000
folios en el que se cita a comparecer
ante el tribunal a más de un centenar de
testigos para aportar nuevos elementos
sobre las circunstancias de la muerte de
thomas sankara y doce de sus
acompañantes el 15 de octubre de 1987
ese día y thomas sankara y sus doce
compañeros fueron ametrallados según la
expresión de varios testigos por un
comando formado por miembro de la
seguridad del ex compadre testigos
mencionan la visita de blancos que
llegaron a estacionar el sistema de
escuchas telefónicas en el cuartel de
hania
llenar de tensión es un acusado mismo
admitió haber recibido una misión
francesa enviada por la presidencia
escuchamos ahora la reacción de mariam
shankar a la viuda del líder asesinado
de opinión
creo que los burkineses y la opinión
pública en general sabe ahora quién fue
el presidente thomas sankara quien fue
el individuo quién fue el político lo
que quería el que querían también los
que lo asesinaron le habían llamado de
todo pero ahora sabemos que el hombre
iturralde descubrí tuzsa o se mentan que
el arte no me empeñé y justamente antes
de cambiar de tema recordemos quién fue
thomas sankara
thomas sankara icono panafricana y
revolucionario tenía 34 años cuando
llegó al poder tras un golpe de estado
como jefe de estado sus prioridades
fueron sanear las finanzas públicas
mejorar la situación sanitaria y proveer
el acceso a la educación
profundamente antiimperialista se negó a
que su país dependiera de la ayuda
internacional y por tanto abogó por la
autosuficiencia
carismático y excelente comunicador el
joven líder gozó de una inmensa
popularidad
adelantado a su tiempo y considerando la
emancipación de la mujer una prioridad
multiplicó las medidas en su favor
oxfam
y
consciente también de que la protección
del medio ambiente era una urgencia se
comprometió en la lucha contra la
desertización en 1987 pronunció su
último gran discurso dos meses antes de
su muerte pidiendo a los países
africanos que nos pagaran su deuda pero
su cuestionamiento del orden establecido
fue percibido como una amenaza por
muchos líderes africanos y europeos el
15 de octubre de 1987 fue asesinado por
un comando su antiguo amigo íntimo y
compañero de armas les compaoré asumió
entonces la presidencia poniendo fin al
período revolucionario de burkina faso
más de tres décadas después de su muerte
el padre de la revolución burguesa sigue
siendo un símbolo inmortal en la memoria
africana
de burkina faso pasamos al vecino mali
durante cuatro días del 27 al 31 de
marzo en el pueblo de mora en el centro
del país se desarrolló una mortal
operación antiterrorista por parte de
las fuerzas armadas malienses muras se
encuentra en una zona controlada desde
hace años por los yihadistas el ejército
maliense que ha visto avanzar al enemigo
de forma constante desde el inicio de la
guerra en el norte del país en 2012
decidió pasar a la ofensiva en mora
ejecutando a 300 personas sospechosas de
ser ya listas o de brindarles apoyo en
un informe publicado el martes 5 de
abril human rights watch denunció la
masacre describiéndola como el peor
episodio de atrocidades desde el
estallido de la violencia diez años
atrás
escuchemos a la directora de human
rights watch para áfrica occidental-
no nos posicionamos sobre operaciones
militares
pero sobre lo que si nos posicionamos es
la forma en que se trata a los detenidos
y lo que pareció ocurrir esta vez fue
que se ejecutó a los presos en masa en
lo que parece haber sido un castigo
colectivo contra las comunidades
en las que el gobierno acusa de albergar
y apoyar a los grupos islamistas armados
fuertemente son scripts otro país otro
tema el pasado 7 de abril urban da
inicio la conmemoración de los 28 años
del genocidio perpetrado contra la etnia
tutsi ocurrido entre abril y julio de
1994 durante esos tres meses oscuros de
la historia del país la violación fue
utilizada como arma de guerra para
deshumanizar a las mujeres tutsis emilia
en una sobreviviente decidió convertirse
en terapeuta y dedicarse a las mujeres
que sufrieron violencia sexual en el
siguiente informe
marian con él nos lleva a conocer a
emiliano y a su lucha
a
muchos en el western llegando aquí casi
todos los estudios fueron exterminados
durante el genocidio de
1994 sólo unos pocos sobrevivieron como
emiliano en la fiesta es la parte
relacionada con mi trabajo porque quería
continuar con mi labor de acompañamiento
a las mujeres compañía el ifam fue en
2004 cuando estaba psicoterapeuta
decidió dedicarse a las mujeres víctimas
de violencia sexual que en el entonces
se utilizaba como arma para someter y
humillar las mujeres tutti
es la sociedad la que no deja de
recordarles que si han pasado por esto
es por su culpa hoy se les acusa de
exagerar su sufrimiento
por eso una vez al mes además de su
trabajo organiza grupos de discusión
voluntarios con las mujeres durante dos
horas estas mujeres supervivientes del
genocidio y la violación cuenta su miedo
pero también su trauma
veo constantemente las imágenes de mi
amiga que fue asesinada delante de mí
estas imágenes me persiguen
y hace un año milián decidió permitir a
estas mujeres
anticiparse a través del trabajo es el
caso de libelo
trabajar hoy es una fuerza para mí antes
pensaba que era la única que había
sufrido las atrocidades del genocidio
pero conocer a las otras mujeres y
trabajar para la asociación me ayudó a
tener fuerza y luego encontré una gran
familia que había perdido pero a pesar
de su determinación de seguir adelante
las cosas sigue siendo difíciles para él
y vélez especialmente en abril mes de la
conmemoración del inicio del genocidio
cuando siente que bieber las diversas
violaciones que llegaron a un embarazo
la mujer danger propone nación cuando
nació mi hijo no le di el pecho le dije
que le odiaba a que le deseaba la muerte
desde que me uní al grupo me he abierto
y me aceptaba nunca
y según las cifras oficiales casi medio
millones de mujeres han sido violadas y
el 65% de ellas tienen el vih
hablemos ahora de la situación sanitaria
en el continente las cifras oficiales de
kobe 19 en áfrica muestran que el
continente se ha salvado de las peores
consecuencias de esta crisis algo que
sorprende a la comunidad científica
preguntamos a nuestra experta en salud
si esta percepción es real
existe esa percepción de que áfrica no
ha sido golpeada por la pandemia de kobe
19 de la misma forma que lo han sido
otros lugares del mundo sobre todo
cuando lo comparamos con las
expectativas que muchos teníamos sobre
la catástrofe que podría llegar a ser la
llegada del comit 19 al continente
africano sin embargo las cifras nunca
reflejaron esa catástrofe en parte
porque los conteos oficiales muchas
veces fallaron en reportar todos los
contagios y todas las muertes pero ahora
con algo de perspectiva del tiempo por
ejemplo la organización mundial de la
salud ha podido afirmar que dos tercios
de la población africana tienen
anticuerpos contra el cob y 19 es decir
que dos tercios de la población se ha
contagiado del virus también han tenido
en cuenta el exceso de mortalidad cuando
miramos ese exceso de mortalidad se
calcula que el de hecho la tasa de
muertes por ccoo 1.019 podría haber
llegado a ser de 200 por cada 100.000
habitantes una taza que aunque sea menor
que es aproximadamente la mitad que en
europa no deja de ser muy significativa
y definitivamente mucho más alta que la
que muestran las cifras oficiales
explican esta baja mortalidad relativa
con algunos factores como por ejemplo la
juventud de la población africana
dinámicas sociales distintas y también
hasta factores genéticos que podrían
influir en esa baja mortalidad
también le preguntamos si el racismo
puede haber influido en la percepción
que se tiene del desarrollo de la
pandemia en áfrica en varias ocasiones
ciertas mirada sesgada sobre el
continente africano han tenido
influencia en como hemos hablado como
hemos pensado y como relatado la
pandemia en ese continente por ejemplo
con el tema de los factores genéticos
que puede responder más a una visión
algo racista sobre la población africana
de que tienen que ser más fuertes y más
resistentes y que en realidad no está
basada sobre ningún estudio científico
que muestre que eso sea verdad o que la
población africana tenga ningún tipo de
protección especial contra el cubit 19
por otro lado también ha fallado en
nuestra mirada sobre el continente
africano ver que y confiar también en
los sistemas de salud de muchos países
africanos que realmente están muy
preparados uno para enfatizar la
prevención de enfermedades contagiosas y
dos para hacer frente a crisis de salud
pública como ya lo han hecho en el
pasado y por tercera por tercera ocasión
han también hemos visto que realmente
las imágenes de la pandemia tal y como
las esperábamos como vimos en nueva
york' como vimos en italia de morges
desbordadas de hospitales también al
borde del colapso eso no ha sucedido en
ningún caso en los países africanos
porque pues en parte también por un
problema de acceso a la salud es muy
difícil para un porcentaje amplio de
población de países africanos acceder a
la salud formal entonces el hecho de que
las imágenes no se hayan correspondido
con lo que nosotros proyectábamos que
debía ser una pandemia o como se debía
haber una pandemia puede haber hecho que
nos hayamos perdido realmente como ha
sido la crisis sanitaria en el
continente africano
hasta aquí y áfrica siete días gracias
por su sintonía y sigan con nosotros
[Música]